looking for ways to easily and securely
share data and insights across
organizational boundaries give me one
minute and i'll show you how with google
cloud analytics hub
analytics hub is an exchange platform
that reduces friction for publishers and
subscribers for sharing data
machine learning models and other
analytics assets
within a strong security governance and
privacy framework
for example you can augment your
analytics and ml initiatives with
third-party and google data sets you can
share assets with your partner network
or within your own organization
and if you're a data provider you can
build out a monetization program
because it's built on bigquery google's
petabyte scale cloud data warehouse
there are no servers to deploy or manage
so administration is a breeze
as a data publisher you can share data
with as many subscribers as you want in
real time
without having to replicate your data
you can quickly build a catalog of
analytics-ready data sources with
granular permissions that allow you to
deliver data to exactly the right
audiences
then you can track and manage
subscribers and see usage metrics
as a subscriber you can easily find the
data you're looking for
combine shared data with your own and
leverage the built-in
ml geospatial and natural language
capabilities of bigquery
you can take advantage of the native bi
support with looker google sheets and
data studio
or connect to any of bigquery's
technology partners
analytics hub is accessible directly
within bigquery making it easy to
publish
curate discover and subscribe to the
assets that deliver immediate business
value
so next time you're looking to use
shared data to drive
innovation to new heights take a minute
to look at analytics hub
to learn more check out cloud.google.com
[Music]
hub